a little more than two years into the
covet 19 pandemic the u.s has recorded
more than one million deaths attributed
to the disease
this is
a extraordinary number of lives lost to
covid the vast majority of would not
have had lost in this time otherwise
the most recent cdc data show covid is
the third leading cause of death in the
u.s after heart disease and cancer and
life expectancy dropped by about two
years as the pandemic took hold so as we
cross the threshold of a million known
copa 19 deaths and look back what we see
is really a surge in deaths that has hit
the u.s unevenly
for some groups the risk of severe
outcomes from covid19 seems to be higher
but who are they and what made them more
vulnerable
the coronavirus in washington state now
reporting at least 15 deaths a cluster
of infections at a nursing home in
kirkland at life care center the
epicenter of the u.s outbreak one of the
first major outbreaks that we saw was in
a nursing home in the seattle area and
that was kind of the harbinger of what
we would see really relentlessly for the
first year of the pandemic
kovit has hit residents of nursing homes
and other types of long-term care
facilities particularly hard federal
data show nursing home residents in the
u.s represent less than one percent of
the overall population but make up at
least 15 percent of recorded covet
deaths there are two reasons for that
number one is people nursing them tend
to be older and secondly they also have
more illnesses since the pandemic began
nearly three-quarters of covet deaths
have been among people at least 65 years
old after vaccines were introduced the
share of deaths among seniors went down
but this group was hit hard again during
the recent omicron surge older americans
are more likely to have underlying
health problems like heart disease and
diabetes that can complicate covet
infections
in nursing homes the highly contagious
virus could infect the frailest people
who were living in close confines it
became clear that it was just really
really difficult to keep the virus out
of these facilities one
issue obviously is that you have staff
who live in the community and come and
go every day
at the beginning of the pandemic
millions of office employees began
working from home but a class of
employees deemed essential including
those who work at nursing home
facilities had jobs that required them
to leave the house
having that kind of frontline job
whether it was healthcare or you know at
a meatpacking plant or elsewhere
meant increased risk of being exposed to
the virus
it's unclear exactly how many people in
a particular profession died from covid
because the cdc doesn't publish covet
death data by occupation but a study
among californians from uc san francisco
founded essential workers like food
service health care and retail employees
faced a greater risk of death in 2020
compared to pre-pandemic numbers
they didn't have the luxury like many of
us had of staying home and sitting
behind a laptop they still had to go out
and be in harm's way
data from the u.s census bureau show
that people with lower incomes are much
less likely to work remotely that group
of course was at greater risk of getting
covet and that group was
disproportionately people of color which
explains
a lot of the eventual racial gap that we
saw in kovaid
while most covet deaths in the u.s are
among white people who make up the
majority of the population
certain non-white groups have a higher
covet mortality rate it's a higher
number than you would expect given their
numbers in the population certainly the
black population and the hispanic
population stand out in that regard
public health experts including those at
the national institutes of health and
the cdc say that disparities stem from
many factors like pre-existing medical
conditions and access to health care
the proportion of underlying illness in
this country is not evenly distributed
by racial groups we know that black
americans are more likely to be sick
with hypertension diabetes than our
white americans
that in turn is a product of
long-standing systems of marginalization
that actually result in greater burden
of illness among black americans
epidemiologists say the true u.s death
toll from covid is likely even higher
than 1 million
this includes deaths that were
misdiagnosed early in the pandemic when
the disease was new and tests were
scarce
so there were probably more
opportunities at that time at least to
misclassify a death as something else
maybe call it influenza or pneumonia for
example instead of coping 19.
excess deaths associated with the
pandemic have reached more than 1.1
million according to the cdc
some of those deaths came from indirect
fallout like deferred health care and
missed health screenings
experts say it will likely take years to
fully realize the pandemic's toll
a million deaths is a million parents
grandparents cousins uncles lovers
friends it's a million people
and
nothing redeems a tragedy like that but
it seems to me
like we are not honoring the tragedy if
we do not learn from the moment so that
we can improve
[Music]